[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 ya está conmigo en el estudio
rosa problemas de rosa muy buena mañana
viernes bienvenida vamos a abrir
entonces esta revista de prensa con un
texto de opinión publicado en el 'new
york times' escrito por we want él es
investigador de gobernanza global además
miembro del partido comunista y ex
redactor jefe de jefe del global times
el periódico oficialista y nacionalista
de chinarras el artículo se titula
porque el pueblo chino ya no admira a
eeuu porque buenos de arrabal bien pues
buena one desde beijing escribe este
texto en que compara la situación actual
con la de los años 90 cuando él era
estudiante universitario y dice en ese
momento mi generación admiraba a china
explica anécdotas como con sus
compañeros de universidad dice son
sintoniza vamos voice of america para
escuchar las noticias de eeuu y del
mundo y perfeccionar nuestro inglés dice
acudíamos en masa a las conferencias que
daban a profesores estadounidenses
cuando venían de visita al campus y en
definitiva dice era un momento
emocionante porque china salía del
aislamiento la pobreza y miraba hacia el
futuro estudiando por un lado la
economía de mercado por otro la igualdad
y cito textualmente otros valores que
hicieron grande a estados unidos- no
hacia rosa pero también el autor explica
que esta admiración por eeuu se perturbó
así es y entre otras cosas cita pues las
guerras de estados unidos en el
extranjero políticas económicas
imprudentes o un partidismo destructivo
pero para mencionar algunos de los
momentos precisos a los que hace
referencia o en wang por ejemplo el
bombardeo que fue calificado por
washington de accidental de la embajada
china en belgrado en
1999 por otro lado dice ya en 2003
cuando muchos chinos ya tenían
televisión dice todos pudimos ver la
carnicería que significó la invasión
estadounidense de irak basada en los
pretextos falsos dice en 2008 china tuvo
que defenderse de la crisis de las
subprimes que digamos dejó a millones de
chinos sin empleo por otro lado el
momento en que obama se embarcó en el
llamado giro hacia asia que cito
textualmente nos dice wenchuán
percibimos como un intento de aliar a
nuestros vecinos contra nosotros por
otro lado la guerra comercial declarada
por trump o el asalto al capitolio que
fue algo según calificada el autor que
fue visto como vergonzoso desde chino
bueno y finalmente lo que vimos
recientemente no la visita de la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi a la
isla de taiwán exacto y lo menciona un
poco como la gota que colma el vaso dice
solo ha decepcionado aún más a muchos
chinos que lo vieron como una violación
de los compromisos de eeuu sobre taiwán
dice sin embargo los estudiantes chinos
todavía quieren ir a estudiar a
universidades de eeuu pero cuando lo
hacen temen la violencia armada por otro
lado los ataques de odio anti anti
asiáticos o ser etiquetados de espías
todo otro tema aparte que a veces hemos
mencionado también dice en resumen una
vez buscamos aprender de los éxitos de
eeuu ahora estudiamos sus errores poder
evitarlos rosa y que dice del rumbo de
china dice que también necesita cambiar
que sin embargo muchos chinos están
contentos con la situación actual de su
país y pone de ejemplo la forma como la
población china
alaba la política de 'cero cobit
emprendida por las autoridades de
beijing para hacer frente a la pandemia
de kobe 19 sin embargo dice que china no
debería excusarse en los problemas
internos que tiene eeuu para evitar así
las reformas internas dice que beijing
debería responder con más calma y de
forma más constructiva a las críticas
que vienen desde el exterior sobre temas
como la política comercial o los
derechos humanos dice en relación a el
vínculo que deberían tener washington y
beijing que algunos de los mayores
desafíos que afronta el planeta en este
momento necesitan de la cooperación
entre entre ambos pero eso no significa
que china tenga que seguir a eeuu por el
precipicio rosa y el south china morning
post' dice que informa de futuras
visitas a taiwán eso es y este medio
explica a pesar de las advertencias de
beijing que dice que los políticos
extranjeros no deberían seguir el
ejemplo de pelosi de la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes de eeuu no dice
aún así hay miembros del parlamento
alemán miembros de la unión del
parlamento de la unión europea que han
declarado que aseguran que van a visitar
taiwán en los próximos meses no dice aún
así bruselas en referencia más bien a la
comisión europeo europea al ramo
ejecutivo dice intenta mantenerse al
margen de esta polémica por un lado
porque lo ve como un asunto entre
washington y beijing por otro lado
porque están muy ocupados con el tema
guerra en ucrania y por otro lado dice
también por este desierto estival del
hemisferio norte no que dice siempre
pausa un poco las relaciones exteriores
de la unión europea y finalizamos lo
sacó una imagen del 'global times' antes
de despedirla eso es con una imagen de
tensión hecha un poco para la ocasión en
la que vemos aquí una mapa de china con
la isla de taiwán haciendo de y de china
con digamos el texto ni un pedazo puede
quedar atrás rosa muchísimas gracias
como siempre por toda la información es
feliz fin de semana nos vemos el lunes
con más de revista de prensa pasamos a
saludar a nuestra primera mitad del día